I understand tipping 20 at a restaurant
when I'm dining in but am I obligated to
tip at a restaurant when I place a to-go
order there's no service provided other
than making a meal and I drove to pick
it up am I wrong here this is kind of
Middle Ground here on the to-go order
dining in I'm outrageously tipping
valets I'm outrageously tipping tipping
at a fast food joint no tipping at the
Starbucks line no this one I'm kind of
going to be 50 50. I got two thoughts on
it one is I don't want to be guilted
into anything I'm with you B almost
never have I regretted being generous
there's very few times I look back
unless I was guilted into it you know
because they're in there working and I'm
just trying I'm doing well God's blessed
me why not you know why not just be easy
with it I do resent this spin thing at
the counter and that is guilting I'm not
doing that usually there's a compliment
as they spin it hey uh you know I love
your hair they'd never say that to me I
never get love your hair